but if I had to drink with someone
living like drink and there's like
there's a too obvious one like obviously
it's [__] Kim Jong-un right you kind
of wanna he drinks no he does
you think my IVs are good in the morning
you know Kim jong-un's IVs are next
you're like I feel up and he's like it's
amphetamine he would be a badass to
drink with I think he drinks hard liquor
uh I think it's Scotch Johnny Walker
Blue
that's what I've heard I don't know why
you heard this but I like this okay so I
say things like that but then I'm sure I
I I I I I don't know if you've ever
partied with someone who just parties a
little different than you and then you
notice like like sometimes like athletes
and then like you're at a strip club and
then they they talk weird to a woman
you're like oh that's not me I'm so
sorry so that would be the thing the
atrocities would be hard to get past
with them not just the atrocity but the
way of being I agree with you I actually
don't like drinking with
rich and powerful people often there's
something weird about them yeah not not
all of them and I don't like I don't
like a drinking meeting like with some
of those let's less
people go like hey uh I'm taking you out
tonight we're drinking yeah and then I
go oh that's not the way I like to do it
it gives me anxiety like
um our lives are very different you and
I yeah we're gonna fraternity no
we could start there yet no I was not
okay
and the differences continue from there
I'm sure so when you get your pleasure
pin uh-huh they take you out and their
whole thing is you're gonna you're
getting you [__] up yeah that energy
is not my energy I don't like that like
it's I just go why don't we just get
drunk and feel really good about
ourselves like I never like took
mushrooms to see Jesus I just wanted to
enjoy Rain-X on a windshield like so
like that that for me
uh is like one of my things so if if Kim
Jong-un flew me to North Korea to drink
with him I'd be like I'd have to start
really getting blackout drunk on the
plane to enjoy drinking with him that
day